la chronique culture du mercredi avec
aux aléas de bissy bonsoir aurélia
penseurs wilfried arrêt de quoi parlons
nous ce soir je vous donne un petit
indice écouter des sons ordre faut
retrouver à qui appartiennent ces rieur
n'ont rejoint devinettes et non ce soir
comme vous l'avez entendu nous allons
parler du rire et donc sur ce plateau
nous avons nadia gourbis bonsoir vous
êtes enseignante chercheuse en gestion
des ressources humaines à l'université
donc de versailles saint quentin mais
également experte du yoga du rire vous
venez ce soir pour nous parler du rire
au travers de cette méthode qui est le
yoga du rire et puis d'une manière un
petit peu plus d'historique nous allons
nous raconter donc l'étape du rire et
puis ces différentes perceptions donc au
travers de l'histoire tout à fait merci
de l'invitation
comment est-ce que j'en suis venu à
m'intéresser au phénomène du rire c'est
un peu de par ma formation initiale j'ai
un doctorat en sciences de gestion et de
parement demain d'enseignement et de
recherche en gestion des ressources
humaines que je j'ai une certaine
sensibilité à tout ce qui est humain à
la dimension humaine dans les prises de
décision j'ai fait j'ai réalisé des
lectures dans le domaine du rire et j'ai
fait le constat suivant la perception du
rire n'a pas été toujours aussi positive
à calais aujourd'hui avec les auteurs de
l'antiquité c'est vrai qu'aristote a dit
le rire est le propre de l'homme
mais à l'antiquité l'homme libre de la
cité l'homme intelligent sages ne doit
pas rire le rire était considérée comme
une des grimaces de la laideur
c'était indécent c'est ce n'était pas
convenable de rire et cette perception
s'est poursuivie pendant le moyen âge le
rire était considéré comme un péché
ce n'est qu'avec la renaissance que leur
hier à regagner un peu de sa valeur
et c'est en quelque sorte anobli et
aujourd'hui on peut dire que le rire est
perçu de manière beaucoup plus positive
très positive d'ailleurs je dirais même
que il ya une ans 30 une
instrumentalisation excusez moi du rire
une instrumentalisation du rire de la
part des spécialistes en communication
lé coach en communication
les orateurs les conférenciers des
politiciens en recours au reer pour
faire passer le message surtout dans
cette période de crise il faut rire il
faut animer à l'audience et même nous
autres les enseignants en pédagogie on
doit introduire une partie ludique dans
nos cours et intéresser les étudiants
maintenant nous sommes venus nous en
sommes venus à la il faut intéresser les
étudiants prévus dans la manipulation
parlerait presque oui on est plus dans
le rire spontané qui permet de
s'exprimer tout simplement d'avoir une
réaction à ces primaires basiques sur un
événement c'est un des trucs ans le rêve
oui s'il ya une part de manipulation
vous avez raison mais c'est pour
intéresser intéressés l'audience pour
capter l'attention de l'audience il faut
des américains 10 tonnes eq speech le le
speech doit être dynamique tonique pour
ne pas endormir l'audience oui ce qui
fait que le rire il ya une forme
d'instrumentalisation du rire l'espèce
il est coach en développement personnel
font le lien entre le rire et la
séduction et de nos jours on assiste à
l'émergence des clubs de rire a alors
dans ces clubs
qu'est ce qui s'y passe quel est le
concept des clubs derrière il faut dire
que le club de rire est née avec les
travaux d'un médecin généraliste indien
de docteur madan kataria qui à qui on a
demandé de lister les bienfaits du rire
sur la santé il s'est dit tiens il ya
autant de bienfaits à leurs crayons des
clubs de rire et il a inventé la
technique des techniques de simulation
du rire voilà il faut provoquer le rire
et ça s'adresse à qui un j'aime pas trop
le terme thérapie lorsque c'est un terme
un peu trop trop ambitieux je pense que
le rire c'est un exercice
c'est une pratique qui nous permet
comment va en salle de sport pour faire
de la gymnastique aller dans un club de
rire pour renforcer cette une
prédisposition au rire sa capacité ça
s'adresse à toute personne qui a envie
d'avoir d'introduire une part ludique
dans sa vie de tous les jours
ça s'adresse à toute personne qui a
envie et d'être un peu plus joyeuse
alors concrètement comment ça se déroule
une séance claquant derrière clanche le
réel
combat là il faut rire allez c'est
maintenant tout à fait comme on fait
comme en fait une séance de club de yoga
du rire yoga du rire comprend un certain
nombre d'étapes cinq minutes de
présentation des bienfaits du rire pour
les nouveaux participants à peu près dix
minutes de relaxation position assise
donc la respiration c'est quelque chose
parce que yoga et rires donc dans le
yoga souvent se décontracte voilà on a
une idée de maîtrise de sa respiration
on voit quelques images en effet de yoga
du rire donc c'est collectif parce que
c'est important d'être d'être plusieurs
d'avoir sont peut-être son propre reflet
aussi dans le rire est contagieux aval
arles le yoga du rire en c'est un
ensemble d'exercices qui combine la
respiration et le rire il ya des
exercices de simulation en provoque au
début et ce que dit le docteur kataria
c'est que le corps ne fait pas de
distinction entre le rire simuler
provoquer et le rire spontané les
bienfaits du rire sont là et les
médecins le disent ça produit et de
l'endorphine qu'ils aient leurs mains du
bien-être donc de dr kataria au début a
réuni une bande d'amis et ils ont
commencé à raconter des blagues mais le
problème avec l'humour l'humour et
culturels mais le rire est universal on
tourne toujours en dérision une
catégorie d'individus avec ses exercices
de simulation de rire en provoque le
rire et ça devient fou rire en eau se
moque de personne
en plus le contact est important comme
vous dites le contact visuel
alors pour moi ça a été je vais là vous
ça a été un tournant dans ma vie avoue
j'étais un peu timide très réservée et
ça m'a permis de dépasser sa timidité
que vous avez vous-même donc pratiquer à
tickets et donc ouvrir à la demande tout
à fait donc la seconde dans l'oreillette
depuis une dizaine de minutes parce que
je vais totalement transparent avec mon
téléspectateur pouvait rien sur le
plateau si je vous le demande je tiens
compte de la perception des gens qui ne
connaissent pas ce concept donc là ça
m'est très difficile mais y aller parce
que les gens qui ont regardé mon boulot
de même
dr kataria invente des exercices de
simulation du rire à titre d'exemple le
rire de la salutation le rire du
milkshake le rayon du téléphone portable
est derrière le plus célèbre du docteur
cabaye et ça marche
oui c'est le rire le plus célèbre et ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'il n'y a
pas de contact visuel dans content
débute une séance les gens ne se
connaissent pas on fait le milk shake
voilà c'est quoi c'est la salutation
fait c'est le milkshake vous avez deux
heures vous verser un verre dans un
autre de sirop et l'autre le deuxième
vers dans le premier vous buvez en riant
en éclats on éclate de rire d'abord
s'aider et claf en fait on s'esclaffe et
ça détend tout le monde et ça détend
tout le monde
voilà leur ya des suites nous avons dix
minutes de rire collectif le rire est
contagieux
nous sommes étalés par terre on ne se
regarde pas ça permet de lever les
inhibitions éventuellement et 15000 de
relaxation après l'euphorie on se
relâche
c'est un peu les techniques de
sophrologie lien ya de la musique douce
et de l'animateur répète des
affirmations positives donc globalement
ça dure quoi une quinzaine de minutes
s'est fait en tout et pour tout
peut-être 12h45 ah oui quand même mal
car accor 45 minutes on sort on recevez
zeine est aussi vide et parce que donc
du coup physiquement physiquement tout à
fait rien ça fatigue
mais oui on contracte les michelin c'est
simple tu as fait mais vous êtes
renseigné vous avez dû l'écouter
j'essayais de régulièrement en vous en
temps réel d'un film à produire au
diamant et du rire on va voir ça
justement peu plus en détail une somme
tout même à les poser la question à
quelques amis noah quelques saint
quentinois quelles sont ses bienfaits
c'est ce qu'il faut pour vivre
correctement se détendre c'est essentiel
on ne rigolait tous les jours c'est
essentiel c'est bon pour la santé
un bien-être jeu j'aime rigoler surtout
entre potes bonne thérapie et du
bien-être si on rigole pas enfin moi
personnellement je sais que si je rigole
pas je suis pas j'ai pas ma dose de rire
par jour je suis pas bien vrai ça détend
ça permet de passer des bons moments de
s'amuser
c'est pour la bonne humeur et puis ça
les stresse et puis quand on rigole mais
c'est bien déjà je n'ai pas le souvenir
mary poppins comme c'est bien trouvé
pour conclure le sujet mais oui c'était
tout à fait représentatifs alors nadia
tebourba donc les bienfaits du rire dit
non concrètement en quoi s'agit sur
notre corps alors là je recommande aux
téléspectateurs les ouvrages du
neurologue henri rubinstein qui
décortique un peu les différents appels
des différents appareils de l'organisme
qui entrent en jeu lors du rire il dit
qu'il y a un axe musculaire d'ailleurs
le rire fait travailler du tout petits
muscles du visage
mesdames c'est un excellent anti rides
ah ben oui le rejet river que samedi
serait retrouvée fait travailler les
muscles jusqu'au jusqu'à la musculature
abdominale et celle des membres il y a
un axe respiratoires on respire et
finalement un axe neurologique il passe
à argy sur la douleur la mémoire et
l'apprentissage et dernièrement il ya eu
des recherches sur le lien entre le rire
et la mêlée maladie d'alzheimer les
scientifiques et neurologue psychologue
psychothérapeute s'intéresse énormément
aux bienfaits du rire sur la santé et ne
faut pas avoir honte à rire
il faut rire chez soi un chez-soi fermé
la porte et riez riez ça fait du bien et
vous fait peur à vos voisins vous serez
tranquille et viendront pas sonné chez
vous c'est pourquoi il ya autant doué
dans l'appartement
moi je suis un pays à une date aussi toi
là j'ai trouvé une cure
vous allez donc intervenir en tant
qu'experte du yoga du rire au café débat
qui aura lieu le 23 février sur la
thématique donc comment perçois ton le
rire aujourd'hui dîtes-nous juste
rapidement quel est votre lien avec le
café débat je suis membre du café débat
depuis trois ans déjà je suis guyancourt
toise depuis quatre ans et demi et j'ai
trouvé dans le café débat un espace des
changes de communication très très
intéressant nous nous réunissons deux
fois par mois pour parler d'un thème
alors sachez qu'on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir fait pas plus j'en sais combien
pour assister et puis on n'est pas dans
une situation passive c'est un samedi
après midi
4h30 16h30 les participants sont dans
une position active participent s'ils
devaient s'ils veulent prendre la parole
le conférencier est certes expert dans
son domaine mais il lance le débat et
c'est aux participants de parts de
donner de donner leur point de vue
tiré de leur propre vécu quotidien le
café débat est très intéressant je vous
invite noter sur vos agendas et rendre
ce sera le 23 février ce thème comment
perçois ton le rire aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup pour tout cette précision
toutes ces précisions pour cette tranche
de rigolade
combien d